buongiorno ciao a tutti si posizione è
rotta questo anche questo soprattutto
questo serve quando uno va per mare si
sono nocciano grafo meglio c'è anologo
se vogliamo essere un po più precisa me
piace più e mi occupo soprattutto di
oceano e clima oceano non oceani perché
in realtà di oceano ce n'è uno solo non
c'era quindi il mio campo di studio ma
anche per me tutto sommato un amico e
gli amici si sa a volte aiutano a volte
vanno aiutati sempre però sarebbe meglio
ascoltarli e girando il mondo seppur ha
colpito dal mal di mare qualche storia
l'ho sentita e oggi vorrei proporre due
perché in fondo vedete anche in questa
regione che vedete nella figura che noi
chiamiamo di solito indistintamente
polinesia già 4000 anni fa le persone
che solcavano i suoi mari con queste
canoe a bilanciere avevano lo stesso
problema dell'uomo moderno conoscere la
propria posizione è importante farlo se
vivi in un contesto come quello delle
isole marshall dove 34 atolli buttati
così a casa o quasi tra le hawaii e
l'australia si staccano dal livello
medio del mare
diciamo per 30 centimetri solo in
altezza perché appena 6 allargo a
pescare un po d'onda la natura canoa non
ti fa vedere più nulla e quindi la tua
posizione è un problema importante
perché ti serve tornare a casa
bene voi direte questo un problema che
tanti hanno avuto le stelle sole qualche
trucchetto per orientarsi in mare l'uomo
l'ha sempre usato giusto i marshall e si
no l'unico popolo che ha usato e usa
ancora le onde come indicatore naturale
della propria posizione e lo fanno lo
facevano e chi è quella capace lo fa
usando uno strumento come questo
bastoncini di navigazione delle isole
marshall una serie di legnetti di cocco
ricurvi piegati in un modo
artigianale con all'intersezione delle
conchiglie questo racchiude
l'informazione di generazione gli
abitanti delle marshall che hanno
tradotto l'andamento delle onde di swell
quelle onde distanti generate da un
vento distante che poi arrivano a
frangere però vicino alla tua costa vi
sarete che siano aiutato da che chalon
da qui che non c'è il vento da
quell'onda è partita da distante sta
arrivando quella è l'onda lunga l'onda
di suelli il marscianese sulla sua canoa
torna muovendo le dita su questa sorta
di abaco perché riconosce l'altezza
dell'onda che colpisce la sua canoa e
una frequenza avendo memorizzato
la generazione ai propri canali
semicircolari quello che è l'andamento
dell'onda muove le dita riconosce
all'incrocio cosa la posizione del
proprio a tollo perché ognuna di queste
isolette respinge in un modo unico con
una musica unica e particolare
l'onda lunga che la colpisce
meglio di un gps sto disteso
avverto quello che avviene sento cosa
accade attorno a me e da questo capisco
dove sono
conosco la mia posizione perché so
leggere l'informazione del mare
cambiamo per un attimo non l'imposizione
questa volta e ci portiamo nella costa
sud orientale dell'isola di oahu hawaii
mattina presto l'oceano è ancora
lasciato salire il sole lo trattiene
all'alba pure siamo già in tanti di
fronte della scogliera di daimon ed
ognuno che guarda l'orizzonte convinto
di saper trovare quell increspatura sul
reef sulla bandiera che ti consente di
smettere di pagare di salire sulla
tavola e cavalcare un'onda le stesse
onde che arrivavano dai dai nostri amici
della marshall arrivano alle hawaii
sembra un onda di stato e non da adesso
è che va a frangere sulla bandiera
cavalchi quest'onda una gioia per chi fa
surf
impagabile è vero effimera ma impagabile
e mentre l'onda ti si srotola sotto la
tavola non sai bene quanto grato tu
dovresti essere alla curiosità di uolter
heinrich news
nato a vienna pensate nel 1917 e tre
settimane fa ha festeggiato per i 101
anni uno dei padri della scenografia
moderna quando cominciò ad occuparsi
delle onde lunghe aveva da poco lasciato
lavoro in banca a new york dove è stato
spedito nel 1932 dalla famiglia perché
in austria amava sciare poco studiare a
dire il vero e perché aveva un anno
banchiere va bè questo aiuta però volta
non amava molto il lavoro di banca i
suoi leones erano altri no si trovava
bene li amava l'onda delle coste
californiane ricomincio da lì a studiare
proprio in un periodo in cui un'altra
onda ben più grave 20 cupa coltiva
l'europa proprio partendo dalla sua
austria
entra in contatto con il mondo della
marina militare americana
proprio per studiare la possibilità di
effettuare degli sbarchi in condizioni
di honda nel mar mediterraneo o nel mare
del nord fino a quel momento le barche
utilizzate per lo sbarco erano questa
sorta di grossi mattoncini lego che
avrete probabilmente visto in tanti
filmati del d day
e queste barche con un'onda solo di un
metro e mezzo d'altezza significativa
però non riuscivano ad operare lo sbarco
era però considerato da tutti una sorta
di inevitabile pena un problema in fondo
una variabile in più in quella che era
una guerra sporca e lontana no per mons
no lui cominciò a studiare questa è una
riproduzione di una delle sue prime
carte la velocità del vento che vedete
nell'asse di sinistra e la lunghezza per
il quale il vento può soffiare e non
vedete nell'asse hicks in basso più un
vento è forte e più a disposizione un
terreno libro sul quale soffiare bene
vuol ter ricavo amano perché all'epoca i
conti si facevano a mano
tutti affidarsi ai primissimi
calcolatori a matita l'altezza dell'onda
che può derivare crescente ovviamente
più intenso del vento è più lunga alla
distanza e anche la direzione dell'onda
che doveva avere quindi lo fece così
bene che queste tabelline commissione il
presidente eisenhower a spostare lo
sbarco del d day dal 5 giugno al 6
giugno del 44 proprio per evitare delle
onde che avrebbero impedito allo sbarco
da parte di quelle di quelle barche
fatte a forma di di mattoncino lego
il resto è storia per noi però rimane
ancora quest'altra geniale intuizione
prevedo oggi cosa accadrà domani nel
caso di munch prevedo il vento di domani
e con il vento di domani io ti posso
fissare una rotta perché prevedo l'onda
di domani
anche questo geniale e queste sono le
due storie posizione è rotta sulle quali
adesso
ragioniamo insieme all'uomo moderno
l'uomo contemporaneo noi che abbiamo
oramai diciamo raggiunto e superato
alcuni limiti planetari globali non solo
per quanto riguarda gli effetti del
cambiamento climatico ma anche per la
perdita di biodiversità per l'uso dei
terreni per lo sfasamento dei cicli
biogeochimici l'uomo contemporaneo
riesce a fissare una posizione e ad
avere una rotta beh in realtà l'abbiamo
scoperto anche oggi le cose stanno
cambiando molto più velocemente di
quanto pensassimo
qualche anno fa e questo non è una
situazione che ci mette molto a nostro
agio accade per le onde si accade per le
onde che sono in alcuni casi non
ripetibili non più ripetibili come lo
sono state per gli abitanti delle isole
marshall cambiano la loro frequenza
quindi non sono più memorizzabili ma
accade anche per la frequenza di eventi
per la precipitazione per lui per i
ghiacci per il clima di intere regioni
queste sta avvenendo in modo molto
veloce
certo rispetto agli abitanti delle
delle marshall possiamo misurare una
grandissima quantità di dati abbiamo
satelliti sensori in mare senza di un
atmosfera ma tutta questa informazione
non riusciamo più a leggere non
riusciamo più a leggere tutta questa
posta che ci arriva e la nostra
posizione cambia di continuo ogni giorno
fissiamo il valore massimo di anidride
carbonica in concentrazione che abbiamo
mai registrato negli ultimi 800 mila
anni
nell'atmosfera dei 10 anni più caldi mai
registrati finora al mondo otto si sono
verificati dopo l'anno 2000 perdiamo una
concentrazione di ghiaccio tale dal polo
nord che possiamo parlare di una massa
che viene fusa ogni giorno pari a 3.000
volte il peso del colosseo
ogni giorno viene fuso e va come acqua
dolce nell'acqua dell'oceano atlantico
tutto questo sta generando un mondo in
parte diverso
uno degli effetti e l'innalzamento del
livello del mare con il quale dovremo
convivere e che sta già adesso dandoci
segnali concreti per disporre una vita
sulle aree costiere totalmente diversa
da quelle che facevamo nello stesso
tempo non riusciamo nemmeno a tracciare
però una rotta perché la rotta per il
futuro l'ha influenzata soprattutto in
prima istanza dallo stile di sviluppo
che noi stessi dovremo darci e anche
questo ci mette in difficoltà quindi
senza una posizione precisa e senza una
rotta non riusciamo in questo momento
nemmeno a fissare le priorità che
dovremmo avere avanza bene lo vedo che
le priorità dicevo certo viviamo in un
mondo complesso dove piccole variazioni
possono verificarsi come conseguenza in
una grande differenza di rotta
parto da una situazione leggermente
diversa arrivo in una destinazione
totalmente diversa invece è successo con
l'atmosfera in poco più di un secolo
abbiamo aumentato il livello di anidride
carbonica nell'atmosfera e abbiamo
portato dallo 0,2 per mille allo 0,4 per
mille
poca cosa pensavamo questione di gas
rari invece è sufficiente per creare un
mondo di un grado più caldo non solo
nell'atmosfera ma anche nel mare e
quindi questa cosa ci sta portando verso
un'altra situazione verso un altro leone
cosa possiamo fare quindi in questo
momento
cosa possiamo fare cosa possiamo
imparare da queste storie di fronte ad
un oceano che cambia riusciamo a dare il
peso importante all'oceano sappiamo per
esempio che l'oceano produce il 50 per
cento dell'ossigeno che respiriamo
sappiamo che incorpora il 30 per cento
dell'anidride carbonica che mettiamo
sappiamo che proprio all'oceano dobbiamo
la stabilità del clima del pianeta
non credo sappiamo che un mediterraneo
più caldo di quasi due gradi rispetto
alla media degli ultimi 50 anni è stato
il principale responsabile di quei venti
così intensi che hanno fatto strage di
milioni di alberi sulle dolomiti
no perché di queste cose non si parla
abbastanza cosa possiamo fare allora io
dal punto di vista della scienza posso
dire cerco di lavorare per una scienza
il più interconnessa possibile dove
fisica matematica chimica biologia si
parlino insieme ma che includano anche
le scienze sociali l'economia la
filosofia come comunicatore
posso aggiungere che la scienza dovrebbe
essere comunicata appunto in tanti modi
efficaci non solo all'interno dello
steccato di uno scienziato ma anche in
contesti per esempio come questa perché
premo su questi due argomenti perché
abbiamo fretta dobbiamo velocemente
diventare consapevoli responsabili di
quello che accadde la stessa
consapevolezza in fondo che avevano
proprio i pescatori delle isole marshall
e quindi direi che nel nostro dubbio
nella possibilità o nell'impossibilità
in questo momento di tracciare una rotta
cosa possiamo fare possiamo forse
cercare di combinare proprio i due
approcci che ho descritto da una parte
le tabelline di muove la scienza la
comprensione delle dinamiche
dell'atmosfera del mare fatta con rigore
il metodo scientifico dall'altra i
bastoncini la capacità di qualcuno di
ascoltare l'amico che non sta bene di
ascoltarlo come facevano gli abitanti
delle isole marshall mettendo insieme
queste due cose forse riusciamo a
tracciare una rotta per il futuro perché
vedete gli abitanti delle isole marshall
andavano a mare dopo che avevano
imparato ad utilizzare i loro bastoncini
prima studiavano imparavano e poi
utilizzavano da questo dipendeva la loro
sopravvivenza la capacità di tornare a
casa di evitare un uragano di tornare
alla capanna con questa modalità
evitavano di far male a loro stessi e
agli altri forse questo potremmo
cercando di fare anche noi chiudiamo
adesso informiamoci approfondiamo gli
argomenti diamo il peso che merita al
ruolo del nostro oceano che il migliore
alleato nel contrasto dei cambiamenti
climatici
facciamolo subito per evitare di farci
troppo male
aiuteremo senz'altro il nostro amico
oceano ma soprattutto consentiremo a lui
di continuare ad aiutare noi grazie
[Applauso]